revue et corrigée stehlé le nom en forme
de calembour du nouveau spectacle du
casino de paris auquel annie girardot
catherine lara et bob decout donne la
dernière main en ce moment le casino de
paris ouvrira donc ses portes vendredi
prochain après une fermeture de deux ans
et demi les efforts du nouveau directeur
jean mais j'en ai bien sûr ceux des
artistes vont donc faire revivre l'une
des scènes les plus populaires de la
capitale
annie girardot sert de guide à francis
pot pour nous entraîner au casino de
paris
on peut avoir joué gabrielle russier où
le docteur françoise gaillard au cinéma
est tombé soudainement amoureuse des
planches du casino de paris pour une
comédienne ce n'est pas incompatible et
c'est tant mieux
bah oui on a fini tard on était super
c'est tant mieux parce que la passion
d'annie girardot pour cette salle très
kitsch chargé d'histoire et de souvenirs
scintillant va peut-être évité au casino
de paris de se voir transformée en
parking
il en était très sérieusement question
l'état de dégradation des coulisses et
déloge le pool amplement
et l'église là un jardin c'est que tu
fais le pari avant c'était lui un
bouquin sur lui et cet adepte de la
révolution et à ce moment là il y avait
juste une façade s'appelait foyer
richelieu et tout l'intérieur c'était un
peu de budget et toutes les ligues
frappe doublée les petites dames légère
tout on était là tout nouveau le pari
venait dîner et caetera et alors il y
avait des taux neige tombera j'ai plein
de jardin
et puis bon évidemment tout ça a été
supprimée on a construit de théâtre et
même l'église de la trinité été abattus
on l'a refaite et je voulais dire aussi
que à l'armistice 1,18
il y avait mûri chevalier et et
mistinguett
et ce soir la mise si c'était la joie
général et à ce moment là tout le monde
les gens qui avaient évidemment loup et
puis c'était la joie lampard is d'un
fait c est superbe et tout le monde est
venu au dernier moment tout le monde
s'est écrasé dans ce casino ils ont fêté
la fin de la guerre voilà sur occasion
de paris c'est superbe top secret sur le
spectacle de réouverture plumes
paillettes
annie girardot descendra tel le fameux
escaliers difficile de savoir la troupe
tout entière veut jouer résolument la
carte du mystère
on fait tout pour la surprise pour la
surprise et le bonheur voilà c'est tout
alors si on est un petit peu comme ça
qu'est ce tu y es vous comprendrez plus
tard pourquoi
et aussi les spectateurs éventuel
j'espère parce que l'on veut qu'ils
aient le même choc que nous avons eues
voilà c'est pour ça qu'on était reine et
qu'on veut pas dévoiler dévoilé parce
que alors au monde un petit bouquin
petit truc un petit machin eu alors
après tu n'as plus couleurs on veut un
gel on veut une joie fois on veut la
donner et à tous les spectateurs tous
les soirs un pari en tout cas est déjà
tenues celui d'un théâtre qui avec revu
et corrigé échappe
heureusement à la pioche des
démolisseurs